So far, the issues that we've been talking about have been mostly system issues,
things like reliability. I'd also like to spend a moment talking about
software engineering side of things, that is building these systems.
First category of issue has to do with requirements. Because non-functional
requirements dominate this sort of situation, the requirements analyst has to
elicit this information from the customers. And of course, it's axiomatic that
the customers aren't always sure of what the requirements should be,
particularly with respect to quality of service. That is, some kind of
measured understanding of how the system is going to deal with these
non-functional situations. Second concern of software architecture. Recall,
I've been stressing throughout the course that the key element of coming up with
a good solution architecturally is how it's going to deal with a non functional
requirements, a corollary to that is in coming up with the architecture and
choosing the connectors how do those connectors relate to a middleware solutions
that we have. Can, for example, define an appropriate middleware technology for
dealing with one of the connections we've selected to be included in
the architecture. Third software engineering issue has to do with some design
questions. Whenever you have a distributed application you have a network.
Whenever you have a network you have latency. That is delays in message passing.
How is your system going to deal at the software level with this latency.
Are there timeouts, are there the implementation of some kind of protocol for
resending, and so on. Another key question at the design level
as far as distributed applications are concerned is statefulness.
You know that the web applications often are stateless.
That is, every time you interact with the server,
the server has to treat your interaction as a self-contained unit without
relying on any variables retaining values. Of course the database sitting there
can serve as a persistent but heavyweight way of keeping track of state.
The question from the designer then is how they're going to deal with this.
One solution is, you've seen probably with respect to cookies,
that is the server sends back some of its state to the client,
which then returns that information on the next next interaction. And then
there's just the general question of concurrency. How is synchronization going
to be performed, how can you ensure you don't run into any of the problems like
dead like, dead lock or making sure that everyone of the pieces of the system
has some kind of interaction on a timely basis that is, that it's live